اخبار عمليه طوفان الاقصى
بايجاز اهلا بكم ارتفاع عدد الشهداء
الفلسطينيين الى اكثر من
2800 وعدد المصابين الى نحو 100 الا
وتحذيرات من كارثه بيئيه مع وجود جثامين
اكثر من الف شهيد تحت الانقاض في حين قالت
سلطات القطاع ان المواطنين يشربون مياها
غير صالحه
للشرب تواصل الغارات الاسرائيليه الكثيفه
على غزه والقسام تقول انها قصفت اسدود وتل
ابيب ردا على استهداف المدنيين على الحدود
الشماليه اشتباكات مع حزب الله والجيش
الاسرائيلي يعلن تعزيز قواته ويقول انه
سيرد بكل حزم على اي
عمليه بايدن يقول ان احتلال اسرائيل لغزه
سيكون خطا ولكن دخولها للقضاء على حماس
ضروري ووزير خارجيته يعود الى اسرائيل
لاجراء مباحثات بعد جولته بعدد من الدول
العربيه في حين قال الاتحاد الاوروبي ان
المعاناه الانسانيه لا يمكن ان تكون ورقه
مساومه ودع لمنح الامم المتحده حق الوصول
الى غزه دون
عوائق مقتل طفل فلسطيني في السادسه من
عمره ب 26 طعنه في ولايه الينوي الامريكيه
كما اصيبت والدته في حادث اعتبر جريمه
كراهيه بسبب حرب غزه بايدن وصف عمليه
القتل بالوحشيه وشدد على رفض
الاسلاموفوبيا الى
اللقاء
ه